I don't want to know.
I'm going to see you.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Continuing
in
the book of fasting, the chapter
regarding upon whom fasting ing is
binding upon whom fasting is obligatory.
And so we mentioned yesterday that
fasting is obligatory upon anyone who
meets five
five points of criteria.
Five
points of criteria.
And for females there is an additional
which could be counted as a condition
could be counted as a something that
bars a person from fasting a difference
of categorization.
But the point is is that it is five
points of criteria. Whoever has these
five points of criteria
meets them simultaneously. Fasting is
obligatory upon this p upon this person.
He mentions Muslim.
So it is the Muslim who is sane
over the age of puberty or of the age of
puberty healthy and a resident and for a
female
that she not be in a state of menration
or postpartum.
And the point here is that you'll find
that some scholars mention this as an
additional
piece of criteria while others
categorize this as being something that
is in the vein of illness. It's not an
illness obviously, but it is in the
vein.
And so we discussed what is meant by
Muslim. We discussed what is meant by
sane. We discussed what is meant by
the age of puberty. Now we will discuss
what is meant by health.
Health
in the terminology of the faukah with
respect to fasting
is
one of three types of people or one of
three types of illnesses. Okay. The
first type is a person whose illness is
increased by fasting. So fasting
directly impacts their
condition, directly impacts their
illness.
And so if they fast, it directly
increases or intensifies their illness.
That's one.
Number two, fasting doesn't
doesn't cause their illness to
worsen. However, fasting
prohibits
their recovery. So, it slows their
recovery. You've got one person who
fasts and fasting now is detrimental to
their health. It positively harms them.
this person is haram for them to fast.
Then you've got another person whom
fasting doesn't necessarily
increase their illness, but it does
hinder their recovery.
Right? This is an issue of debate which
is better for them to fast or to break
their fast. But all of the scholars
agree that this type of illness is
permissible to fast is permissible to
break one's fast. So notice when we
discuss difference of opinion it it
always sometimes
to the untrained eye
people often times will hear you know in
the books of Phil and the way that
scholars speak as if everything is a
difference of opinion and that is not
the case at all.
Most of the legislation of Islam, the
huge majority, the vast majority, the
overwhelming majority
of
the laws of Islam are
a point of consensus. They are agreed
upon. They don't differ on those. Like
if you think about it, salah, all the
scholars agree that it's obligatory. All
the scholars agree that it's five times
a day. All the scholars agree in the
number of for each. All the scholars
agree. Most of it is agreed upon. All of
the scholars agree that a person stands
and then makes and then stands again and
then makes sujud and then sits and then
makes sud. All of this is agreed upon.
What is disagreed upon?
Some details.
some details and number two what is
better. This is where things start. We
start to have differences of opinion.
Right? Not yes or no, but which is
better in which case or scenario.
This is where the difference of opinion
really starts to take place. These are
details. The majority of Islam is agreed
upon. Alhamdulillah.
A person may say, "Well, then if that's
the case, why are the books of Fil so
voluminous? Why are they so big? And why
is it that every time you open a book of
Fil, it seems to be issues that are
disagreed upon?" We say because the
aren't going to write about things that
are agreed upon. The books of f largely
are written in order to discuss and
debate the issues of contention.
So it's taking a magnifying glass
and focusing it on the issues which are
differed upon. That's why the books of
seem the way they are. However, the
majority of Islam is an issue of
consensus
and this in itself is a miracle. So we
have a very small minority here maybe
10% maybe less actually of the laws of
Islam which are differed upon and even
that 10% or 5% what's differed upon is
not yes or no but what's good and better
and what's bad and what's worse that's
what's differed upon right a difference
of opinion of one says yes and the other
says no stark opp opposites in this way
is rare. Alhamdulillah. That's not only
in the laws and the in the issues of but
also in the of the Quran. To find an
verse where
one companion
or scholar of
comes to the conclusion of yes and the
other comes to the conclusion of no. For
instance, what what we mean here is is
direct conflict is very rare is very
rare. Maybe a handful of places in the
Quran. Aside from that, most of Islam is
agreed upon. So,
back to the types of illness or the the
way that fasting affects illness, who is
allowed to break his fast? Well, we say
a person who is ill. This is agreed
upon. Number two,
if the person fasts, it increases his
illness. All the scholars agree it is
haram for this person to fast. Okay.
The second case, if a person fasts, it
hinders his recovery. It slows his
recovery. Doesn't increase his illness,
but it slows recovery.
This is permissible for this person to
break his fast. However, is it better
for him to break his fast or not? That's
an issue we will get into inshallah. The
third type is someone whose illness is
not affected directly by fasting.
However, it is indirectly affected by
fasting.
What is meant by indirectly affected?
that a person is taking some kind of
medicine for instance that would
normally break his fast. This medicine
can't be taken while he's fasting and
not taking his medicine
will either increase his illness or slow
his recovery. So the fasting and the
illness are not directly
are not directly impact
as cause and effect but there is an
indirect
effect that fasting has and this person
is permissible for him to break his
fast. All these three types are agreed
upon amongst the scholars.
They differ now on what is better right?
Is it better to fast and push through in
Ramadan so that you're fasting with
everyone during the month or is it
better to break your fast because it's
an allowance that Allah has given you
and then to make it up at a different
or a later date. This is an issue which
the author will discuss in the next
chapter.
So these are the types of illness. A
person who is is healthy
whom is obligated to fast is a person
who fasting does not increase his
illness. Fasting does not impede his
recovery. Fasting does not indirectly
affect his illness. These are the three
types. These three if a person has one
of them they break their fast and make
up a day. Now, what kinds of illnesses
are we talking about here? I mean, does
it have to be mortal illness?
Does it have to be I'm going to die if I
fast? Does it have to be that drastic?
Or could it could it be something as
slight as a headache or a migraine? The
scholars have discussed this. The
correct opinion is illness is illness.
And when a person is affected by any
illness, even if it's a momentary
illness a headache, they are
permitted to break their fast because of
this. They are permitted to break their
fast because of this. And you know, we
have other instances of this, a
headache, a toothache, right? some
kind of very intense pain that a
person is experiencing something that
will make their fasting miserable.
The point of fasting is not to take you
to the brink of death or to make you
feel you're at the brink of death.
This doesn't accomplish anything. This
doesn't help. The point of fasting is to
place you in a position of vulnerability
and slight discomfort that will remind
you of your mortality and can act as a
microcosm of our time here on this
earth. That's really what fasting is.
You know as human beings it's very
difficult for us to zoom out and look at
the big picture whether it's with size
or whether it's with u time right you
guys hear astronomers sometimes
they say it's 600 billion trillion light
years what does that mean it might
as well be one inch for the average
person we have no way of really
conceptualizing such a thing however
what we do is we take a microcosm
right so if we say okay the distance
from here to Mars is whatever you know
light years or whatever it is I I'm not
an astronomer but you get the point
it doesn't really mean much but if I
were to say the distance between Earth
and Mars relative to the rest of the
perceivable universe is the
thickness of a credit card in our world.
Well, that now means something, right?
It's something tangible. We can actually
it kind of brings it to life. And this
is what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
for us in the Quran. In all of the
parables of the Quran, the Quran's
parables are there to take these big
subjects eternity you know
100 years or or or 80 years or 70 years
being very brief and to give us an
example
that is tangible. So what does he tell
us about the life of this world? If I
say especially to a young man, I say
70 years on this earth is a flash
in the pan. Well, a young man hasn't
experienced 70 years. They can't even
conceptualize that. And so it doesn't
really mean anything to them. In their
mind, 70 years is a long time. You know,
it doesn't sound such a bad deal.
But then when we zoom out and we take a
microcosm and Allah tells us the life of
this world is a rain that comes
down on a land. It grows its crops and
then at harvest time it is harvested and
you see the crops as if they never were
alive before. Right? And this imagery
that we get now we see the life of this
world sped up. We can conceptualize it
now because we've all experienced that.
This is what fasting is supposed to do.
It is a simulation of our life here on
this earth and our time with Islam and
the laws of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
When we're fasting, we have discomfort
and we feel we want to break our
fast and we might even but then we make
ourselves be patient by focusing on the
moment at hand by saying there's only a
couple hours left by looking at the sun
etc. And then we get through it. And so
we stop oursel in the moment so that we
can rejoice at the end. And as soon as
we break our fast, all the troubles of
that day disappear immediately as if it
never happened. You won't find someone
who has PTSD
from fasting because it was so terrible
that they are scarred for life. No,
it's something that immediately is gone
as soon as you break your fast. And that
is the life of this world. It is just
that. these few years that we live
on this earth, we want to do something
but we stop oursel from doing it. We
hold out and then the angel of death
comes and as soon as the angel of death
comes for the believer immediately
it's that first drop of water on
your tongue when you break your fast the
dunya is gone. It melts away as if it
never was and it was nothing but a
distant memory. This is what we are
taught in fasting along with other
things gratitude for what we take
for granted and so forth. But fasting is
not supposed to be so egregious, so
terrible that the person is in utter
misery throughout the day because
they're sick or ill or too old or
breastfeeding or traveling or anything
else. This is why the slightest
you know the slightest difference in
norm allows you to break your fast
because that's the purpose of fasting.
It's not supposed to act as a as a
hardship. It's supposed to act as a
meditation, a a practice. It is
something that we practice and we do. It
puts us in slight discomfort and it
gives us a different view of the world.
We see the world in a different light.
Subhanahu
[Silence]
Glorious.